-Before we get to that,
the president threatened
to go to war with Congress
and now he
and his Attorney General
are doing exactly that.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-For the first two years
of his presidency,
Trump enjoyed complete immunity
and freedom to do
whatever he wanted
because Republicans in Congress
let him get away with it.
But then, after Democrats
won back control of the House
in November and gained the power
to investigate him,
Trump threatened to go to war.
-If they start investigating
you,
can you compartmentalize that
and still continue
to work with them
for the benefit of the rest
of the country --
-No.
-Or are all bets off?
-No. If they do that,
then it's just --
All it is is a war-like posture.
-I can't exactly imagine Trump
in a war-like posture.
He spends most of his time
in a duck-like posture.
[ Laughter ]
If he were at
the Battle of Winterfell,
he wouldn't have been
on the front lines
or fighting a dragon.
He would have been
sitting under a tree
in his golf cart.
[ Laughter ]
But now Trump and his team
are showing us their
war-like posture
after his Attorney General
William Barr
refused to show up
for a hearing today
in the House Judiciary Committee
to answer questions
about Special Counsel Robert
Mueller's report.
Barr refused to show up
specifically
because the committee wanted to
let lawyers ask him questions.
-William Barr
informing the house panel
he will not testify today
as scheduled.
He had been scheduled to testify
to the House Judiciary Committee
about his handling
of the Mueller report.
But Barr rejected
the committee's plan
to have one of its staff lawyers
question him alongside
lawmakers.
-We cannot permit
the administration to dictate
to Congress how we operate.
He is terrified of having
to face a skilled attorney.
-And I'm sure he is.
Usually when you work for Trump,
the only attorney you have
to face is this guy,
and he is definitely not
skilled.
He looks like he can't believe
he's the president's lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy always looks like
the last frame of a clip
from "America's Funniest
Home Videos."
if you tuned in late and saw
this, you'd immediately say,
"Oh, that guy just got
hit in the nuts by a seesaw."
[ Laughter ]
So with Barr
refusing to show up,
Democrats decided to make a show
of his cowardice
by holding a hearing with
an empty chair
where Barr would have been
sitting.
And then immediately after
the hearing,
Democrats used the opportunity
to slam Barr
for refusing to show up.
-I don't feel that I can trust
anything that
the Attorney General is saying
because I don't know who
the Attorney General works for.
-Attorney General Bill Barr
is now one of the most dangerous
men in Washington, D.C.
-The so-called Attorney General
is abrasive, evasive,
and unpersuasive.
-Man, this confirms
everyone's worst fear.
If you don't show up to a party,
the people who do are gonna
talk [bleep] about you...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...in rhyme!
But Democrats didn't stop
at just calling out Barr.
Congressman Steve Cohen
decided to mock him
by putting a glass chicken
in Barr's place
and bringing out a bucket
of KFC.
And then he brought out
the chicken statue again
during an interview
after the hearing
to really hit the point home.
-Representative Steve Cohen
of Tennessee
started eating a bucket
of Kentucky Fried Chicken
this morning while lawmakers
and the press
waited to see if Barr
would show up.
-Tennessee Democrat Steve Cohen
then placed a chicken statue
and a bucket of KFC
in front of the empty chair,
poking fun at Barr's refusal
to appear.
-Chicken Barr
should have shown up today
and answered questions.
[ Laughter ]
-We are looking at images of you
at that committee hearing today
with what appears to be a bucket
of fried chicken.
And -- Oh, there it is.
You brought props, I see,
with you here.
What is the message
you're trying to send?
-The message is that Bill Barr
is a chicken.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh.
Is that the message? I'm, uh...
I'm not sure we got it, pal.
[ Laughter ]
Also, dude, if you want KFC,
just order KFC.
It's fine. You don't need to
tie it into the hearing.
"And he's probably not here
because he knew
we'd be hitting him with
a McFlurry of questions!"
[ Laughter ]
So Barr decided not to show up,
and yet Republicans
on the committee
still wanted time to complain.
Not about Barr,
but about the Democrats,
like Congressman Matt Gaetz.
Gaetz tried to interrupt
the committee chairman
as he was wrapping up
the hearing,
but he was only able to get
a few words in
before his mic was cut off.
-We need the information without
delay.
The hearing is adjourned.
-Mr. chairman, I --
-And we'll do so with trampling
minority rights.
-It's gonna be, Mr. Chairman,
where there's not going to be
a recognition of members
who seek legitimate inquiry
as to the procedures --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, forget muting someone
on Twitter.
Turns out you can mute him
in real life.
Seriously,
can we please try that
next time Trump holds a rally?
-Look, it's a rigged system.
Okay?
If I told you how --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, that was it. That was it.
Barr just refused to show up
and answer questions
about how he handled
one of the most
highly anticipated reports
in modern political history.
And that might be because
when he faced
skilled questioning
from experienced Senators
in a hearing yesterday,
he often had no answer.
Like when Senator Kamala Harris
asked Barr if anyone
in the White House
had ever asked him to open
an investigation into anyone,
and Barr clearly did not
want to answer the question.
-Has the president or anyone
at the White House
ever asked or suggested that you
open an investigation of anyone?
Yes or no, please, sir.
-Um, the president
or anybody else?
-It seems you'd remember
something like that
and be able to tell us.
-Yeah, but I'm trying to grapple
with the word "suggest."
I mean, there have been
discussions of matters
out there that --
They have not asked me
to open an investigation,
but --
-Perhaps they've suggested?
-I don't know.
I wouldn't say suggest.
-Hinted?
-I don't know.
-Inferred?
You don't know? Okay.
-If it takes you that long
to answer something,
the answer is yes.
If you go in
for your performance review
at Chipotle and your boss says,
"Just one last question, Brad.
Have you ever wrapped
your genitals in a tortilla?"
[ Laughter ]
And Brad says, "Uh...
I'm trying to...
trying to grapple with the word
'wrap,'"
[ Laughter ]
the answer is yes,
Brad wrapped his [bleep]
in a tortilla.
That happened.
So Barr lied about
Mueller's findings
before anyone else
got to see them.
That's why Mueller
sent his letter to Barr
complaining about the process.
A letter he sent in March,
but which we only found out
about this week.
And when he was asked about that
letter at his hearing yesterday,
Barr basically just
shrugged it off
and specifically complained
about the tone.
-This letter was
an extraordinary act.
A career prosecutor rebuking
the Attorney General
of the United States.
I know of no other instance of
--
But he was also
a political appointee
and he was a political appointee
with me
at the Department of Justice.
I don't -- you know,
the letter is a bit snitty,
and I think it was
probably written
by one of his staff people.
-Sorry, did you call it snitty?
Are you the Attorney General
or the Dowager Countess?
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know, of course
he was snitty.
He spent two years
working on a 400-page report
about a criminal conspiracy
to interfere
in a presidential election,
and then you wrote a four-page
summary lying about it.
I'd be snitty, too.
It's like if Michelangelo
unveiled the Sistine Chapel,
and then the pope just put
a plaque under it that said
"Two Dudes Touching Fingers."
[ Laughter ]
So Barr lied to the American
people and to Congress,
and now he's just not showing up
to hearings at all,
which means the next thing
Congress should do
is call Mueller himself
to testify
so we can actually hear from
the guy who wrote the report.
Democrats in the House --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Democrats in the house
have said they want to do that.
But in the Senate, Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham,
chairman of
the Judiciary Committee,
said flat-out he definitely will
not call Mueller to testify.
-Why not call for Mueller
to testify?
-Because I'm not going to do
anymore.
Enough already. It's over.
-No, it's not over just because
you said it's over.
We should hear from Mueller,
because for one thing,
we never do.
I mean, I don't even know
what his voice sounds like.
Maybe he sounds
like Bobcat Goldthwait
from "Police Academy."
-[ Zany voice ] And I'd like
to discuss with you something
that would be vital
for you to know.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪